hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live über 500 Tage schon greift Russland
die Ukraine von mehreren Seiten an
schießt mit Drohnen und Raketen auf
Dörfer und Städte am Tag aber vor allem
auch nachts die Vereinten Nationen
schätzen Ende Juli die Zahl der
ukrainischen allein nur der ukrainischen
zivilen Todesopfer auf mehr als
9.300 seit Beginn der russischen
Invasion die tatsächliche Zahl die
dürfte sogar noch höher liegen die
ukrainischen Soldaten kämpfen im Süden
und Osten des Landes und schon oft haben
wir für euch die militärische Lage
eingeschätzt die aktuelle Lage auch das
wollen wir heute wieder tun mit der
Frage heute sind Russlands Truppen zu
stark um wirklich einen Durchbruch zu
erzählen denn es gibt immer mehr Tote
und Verwundete an der Front
Militärexperte Markus Kolb wird mit uns
sprechen aber wir schalten auch live in
die Ukraine und sprechen über den
Beschuss von Rettungskräften und
Zivilisten stellt gerne dazu eure Fragen
Livestream oder auch per Mail und jetzt
direkt am Anfang gleich zugeschaltet ist
mir Markus Keup viele von euch kennen
ihn erst militärökonom an der
Militärakademie der ETH Zürich hallo
schönen guten Tag Herr Kolb hallo guten
Abend in der in den letzten Wochen in
der letzten Woche hat die Ukraine nach
eigenen Angaben ihrer Offensive an drei
Frontabschnitten verstärkt bei bachmut
und zwei Orten zwei Gebieten in der
Region saporisa wie weit konnte die
Ukraine denn in die russische
Verteidigung vordringen ihre
Einschätzung
und ich denke der Abschnitt über den wir
am ehesten sprechen können ist der bei
robertine das ist der Vorstoß den wir
eigentlich seit seit Juni schon gesehen
haben also von Maler toggnatschka die
t0508 hinunter also in Richtung Süden
und dann quasi von dorstendorf sie
stehen im Moment jetzt muss man
aufpassen welche welcher Seite man
glauben schenkt entweder vor der ersten
Linie oder sind gerade dabei durch die
erste Linie der Russen durch zu brechen
an diesem Punkt das heißt da lohnt es
sich also auf jeden Fall genauer
hinzuschauen in den letzten Tagen
in den nächsten Tagen meine ich man muss
aber auch sagen
viele beobachte erwarten so eine Art
Hollywood Film ja also das ist so ein
Film Reifen Durchbruch jetzt gibt durch
die Grabensysteme oder so
Kämpfe die in den Ersten Weltkrieg das
ist natürlich Unsinn sondern worum es
nach wie vor geht in diesem Krieg in das
das erzähle ich schon seit Monaten ist
in russischen Trupp klar zu machen dass
ihre logistische Position und haltbar
ist das heißt also
dass die Ukraine in der Lage ist nicht
nur die russischen Truppen an der Front
selber anzugreifen sondern auch in ihrem
Hinterland Ihnen die Logistik
abzuschneiden wir werden später in der
Sendung darauf kommen aber das muss man
zusammen sehen also dieser der Angriff
auf die auf die geradenlinie ist nicht
unabhängig von den Angriffen auf die
Logistik es gibt ebenso keinen
großflächigen Durchbruch wie viele das
erwarten durch die gesamte russische
Graben Linie sondern die Idee der
Ukraine ist nach wie vor die Kräfte an
einem bestimmten Punkt zu konzentrieren
und versuchen dort Lokal durchzubrechen
bevor wir jetzt aber alle zu euphorisch
werden muss man auch sehen die erste
Linie also die erste grabenlinie die ist
relativ schlecht besetzt also wenn
überhaupt dann sitzen da die bobix drin
also der das geht nach wie vor das
zynische russische Kalkül dass diese
armen Menschen da zuerst drauf gehen
müssen
entscheidend ist dann eigentlich was in
der zweiten und dritten Linie das sind
dann die besser ausgebildeten russischen
Truppen auch die Restkontingente des WDW
also der eigentlich der
fallschirmtruppen die jetzt quasi in den
hinteren Linien der Gräben sitzen aber
sobald sie da durch ist steht im
Hinterland nichts mehr und genau das ist
der Punkt warum die russischen
militärblogger auch so ein bisschen
nervös werden also wenn Sie lieber zum
Beispiel lesen ist einer der bekannteren
militärblockadea wird schon ziemlich
nervös was diesen Punkt angeht und sagt
also wenn sie dadurch kommen steht
einfach im Hinterland nichts mehr und
das das muss man so ein bisschen
zusammen angucken also sprich es ist
kein Hollywood Film es ist nicht DJ
Reloaded es ist jetzt aber auch nicht so
dass das von von heute auf morgen
passieren würde es ist aber auch nicht
so dass die russischen Truppen sich
jetzt quasi auf Ewigkeit da eingraben
und einfach abwarten können weil ihm im
Hinterland die Logistik abgeschnitten
wird also wie immer ist die Realität ein
bisschen komplexer also mancher ist
gerne wahrhaben möchte aber ich denke so
in entlang dieser Parameter wird es die
nächsten Tage weitergehen sie haben die
Logistik und den Nachschub angesprochen
ein Teil davon zum Beispiel für die
russischen Truppen in dem Gebieten nach
herrson die bekommen ihren Nachschub vor
allem eben von der von Russland 2014
annektierten Krim deswegen versucht die
Ukraine natürlich auch da den Nachschub
zu stoppen indem sie Brücken beschießt
wie die Brücke von Kersch zum Beispiel
aber da gab es auch noch weitere Brücken
die da jetzt eine Rolle gespielt haben
wie groß ist denn der Schaden worum
geht's da und ist der Nachschub von der
Krim also noch möglich
wenn sie mir die Bemerkung erlauben die
Creme ist nicht annektiert sie ist
völkerrechtlich besetzt seit 20 14
dieses Märchen von der angeblichen
Aktion ist russische Propaganda ich muss
immer wieder darauf hinweisen dass wir
uns doch hier bitte auf den
völkerrechtlichen Grundlagen bewegen
sollten bei der Diskussion aber wenn wir
jetzt hier auf diese auf diese
wunderbare Karte schauen da sehen wir
eigentlich die Ideen der Ukraine nämlich
die besteht ganz einfach
daraus aus der Halbinsel Krim eine Insel
zu machen weil es nämlich nur wenige
versorgungsachsen gibt die von der Creme
aus Hineingehen in die südliche Ukraine
und über diese versorgungsachsen wird
die gesamte Südfront der Russen versorgt
also die Idee ist ganz einfach wenn man
diese Logistik ausschalten kann dann
bekommen die russischen Truppen die
jetzt natürlich überall in den Gräben
sitzen Probleme weil sie können dann
zwar in den Gräben sitzen aber Sie
bekommen einfach keinen Nachschub mehr
an Treibstoffen an Munition und so
weiter also wir sehen hier wieder dieses
klassische Motiv auf dass ich immer
wieder Hinweise man soll nicht so viel
Pfeilchen auf Karten einzeichnen dass
man vor allem Militärs gerne sondern man
soll sich die Logistik anschauen weil
langfristig die Logistik darüber
entscheidet wie ein Krieg aus geht wenn
man normal auf die Karte blicken können
dann sehen wir das ähm das von diesen
von diesen vier Brücken wieder
eingezeichnet sind oder diesen vier
versorgungsachsen nicht mehr viel übrig
ist also wenn wir mal durchgehen von von
Osten nach Westen
da hätten wir zunächst mal die die
Halbinsel von arabad oder die Nährung
von arabert über die bekommen sie
allerdings keine Logistik also nicht
mehr im nicht mal im Normalzustand sie
können zwar von catch reinfahren bis
camionskoje aber dann ist erstmal Ende
dann ist Sandkiste für ungefähr 30 km
und die Straße beginnt erst wieder ins
Ziel und ähm die Straße die dann
hineinführt nach genetisches wo sich im
Moment das russische Hauptquartier
befindet also diese diese Straßen oder
Brückenverbindung die ist mittlerweile
beschossen worden das heißt die besteht
nicht mehr also selbst im
unwahrscheinlichen Fall dass Sie bei
arabert irgendwas hineinbringen wollten
geht das nicht mehr wenn wir dann ein
Stückchen weiter schauen nach Osten ähm
dann kommt die Straßenbrücke von John
Garagen geht die Autobahn M18 drüber
auch die hat die Ukraine erfolgreich
beschossen
an die Russen versuchen im Moment wieder
entstanden aber im Moment geht ja
jedenfalls kein militärischer
Schwerlastverkehr mehr drüber vielleicht
kann uns die Regie noch mal die Karte
einblenden
[Musik]
sonst rede ich einfach weiter
dann sehen wir gerade ein ein Stückchen
weiter
im Osten also von der von der John gar
Brücke aus das ist eine eine
Straßenbrücke wie gesagt da geht die
Autobahn im 18 drüber und dann direkt
daneben die Eisenbahnbrücke von siwasch
auch die ist mittlerweile beschlossen
worden und nicht mehr operativ so und
jetzt können Sie sich fragen ja was ist
was ist jetzt eigentlich noch übrig ja
und dazu muss man sich jetzt ein Ort
denken der auf der Karte nicht
eingezeichnet ist nämlich John Koi liegt
etwas südlich
von Brücke und das ist eigentlich das
dass das zentrale Logistik Drehkreuz da
ist sowohl ein wichtiger Straßen
Knotenpunkt also der Eisenbahn
Knotenpunkt und es gibt jetzt nur noch
eine einzige Strecke über die von der
Grimm aus militärische
schwerlastverkehre in die Südwand
hineinkommen können und das ist Allianz
also die Straßen und die Eisenbahnbrücke
bei mir ist das dumme ist nur die führt
aber nicht dorthin wo gerade die
schwersten Kämpfe sind nämlich nicht
nach nach robotine oder mellitopol oder
wachmut sondern nach herson hinein das
heißt also sie müssen jetzt über diese
einzige verbleibende Verbindung an
riesigen Umweg fahren also wenn Sie das
im Auto fahren sind es ungefähr drei
Stunden Umweg das bekommen im Moment die
russischen Touristen auf der Creme zu
spüren und sie sehen also wie wie durch
diese Operation die ganze russische
Logistik so ein bisschen anfällig wird
ja dann kommt dazu die heute ist die
herzbrücke wieder geschlossen worden die
geht mal auf mal zu also es ist ziemlich
erotisch im Moment seit heute morgen ist
er wieder zu
und sie sehen so können Sie einfach
keine keine
zuverlässige oder oder großvolumige
Logistik organisierende und das ist das
eigentliche ukrainische Kalkül also
nicht irgendwelche verlustreichen
romantischen Durchbrüche durch
irgendwelche Grabensysteme sondern im
Hinterland die Logistik abschneiden und
gleichzeitig von vorne gegen den Graben
drücken und beides zusammen fährt den
russischen Truppen dann irgendwann den
Eindruck geben
dass ihre Position nicht mehr haltbar
ist wie gesagt es wird nicht von heute
auf morgen passieren aber es wird im
Moment geben wo das den Russen klar wird
und dann ist eben dieser Moment gekommen
wo der Krieg statt tatsächlich
strategisch geworden ist ich habe schon
häufiger gesagt ich erwarte dass für den
Herbst ich bin auch nach wie vor der
Überzeugung dass das passieren kann aber
es ist eben nicht so dass dass man jetzt
so die diesen diesen einen großen Moment
hat wo der Panzer dann im frühen Nebel
durch den Graben bricht ja und das ist
es ist sehr sehr wichtig für das
Verständnis der logistischen Dimension
dieses Krieges dass man sich eben löst
von von diesen Bildern die auch gerne
von von wat nichts vermittelt werden ja
und und sich an die Fakten hält und und
sich die Logistik anschaut so viel für
den Moment zum aktuellsten Stand wir
sprechen gleich weiter mit
Militärexperte Markus Kreuz wir haben
jetzt aber die Möglichkeit wir haben
eben gerade schon die Region
angesprochen mit unserer Reporterin mit
andere Brühl zu sprechen denn sie war in
der Stadt herson heute unterwegs ist uns
jetzt live zugeschaltet aus Odessa hallo
Anna schön dass du da bist
kann alle mich hören ich hoffe doch ich
stelle direkt mal die erste Frage
Entschuldigung ja ich höre dich
wunderbar sehr schön du warst den ganzen
Tag heute über in der Stadt kressen
unterwegs die russischen Truppen sind
von dort gar nicht so weit was hast du
heute erlebt an diesem Tag Interesse
Anna
ja schon die Fahrt in die Stadt ist
absolut Gespenster weil sie durch ein
Gebiet geht das bis November noch von
den Russen besetzt war Frontgebiet war
man fährt dann zerstörten Dörfern vorbei
auf den Feldern haben wir überall Minen
Rheuma gesehen am Checkpoint am Eingang
von Hassan haben die ukrainischen
Soldaten uns gewarnt geht nicht so nah
an den Fluss dort schießen die
russischen Soldaten von der anderen
Seite immer rein und das war so ein
bisschen der Sound dieses Tages wir
haben dauernd der Atelier Beschuss
gehabt in der Stadt wir haben mit
Menschen gesprochen in einem Wohngebiet
die gesagt haben in den letzten Tagen
konnte man eigentlich die Uhr danach
stellen jeden Abend zwischen 22 und 23
Uhr haben die Russen Raketen auf dieses
Wohngebiet ähm abgeschossen Häuser
zerstört wir haben ultra getroffen eine
Frau die ihr Haus verloren hat durch die
Zerstörung des Darms äh das wurde völlig
zerstört und sie sagte wir mussten ich
und meine Kinder wir mussten dieses Haus
Schloss schon hast du schon Beschuss
verlassen und immer wenn ich jetzt ins
Haus komme weil da eben jetzt sie
versucht das wieder her zu richten
dauert dieser Beschuss an im Zentrum von
Person da gibt es Schutzräume mobile
Schutzräume die so ein bisschen aussehen
wie Bushaltestellen wo die Menschen sich
reinflüchten können und ich habe eine
Frau gefragt wie sie unter solchen
Umständen denn überhaupt leben kann und
sie sagte ihre Kinder sind schon aus der
Stadt weg aber sie will auf keinen Fall
gehen sie sagt einer muss doch hier
bleiben wenn wir alle gehen dann hätten
die Russen gewonnen das klingt immer
noch genauso furchtbar wie im Juni als
ich selbst Interesse war nach der
Staudamm Zerstörung dort habe ich den
deutschen Freiwilligen Feuerwehrmann
Nils Tal kennengelernt nils ist
freiwillig in der Ukraine hilft dort ist
im Einsatz seit mehreren Wochen und
Monaten schon in den letzten Wochen in
kianski und ich habe heute mit ihm über
seine Eindrücke in der letzten Tage in
kopiens gesprochen wir schauen in einen
Beitrag von Tim Romberg
ein Wohnviertel in Trümmern pokrowsk in
der Ukraine Montagabend schlagen hier
die russischen Raketen ein neun Tote
mehr als 80 Verletzte darunter sind auch
Rettungskräfte Helfer die getroffen
werden als sie helfen da ist System
dahinter sagt Präsident selensky es gab
mehrere Angriffe die zweite Welle kam
als die Rettungsaktion begann eine
bewusste Entscheidung von Terroristen
den größten Schmerz den größten Schaden
zu verursachen
das russische Verteidigungsministerium
erklärte dagegen seine Truppen hätten
einen ukrainischen Kommandoposten
getroffen
Zivilisten geraten in russischen
Beschuss auch der deutsche Feuerwehrmann
Nils Tal aus Nürnberg erlebt das gerade
in der Ukraine wo er als Freiwilliger
hilft in der Nähe von kubiansk ganz im
Osten des Landes geriet er in
Lebensgefahr diese Bilder hat er selbst
gedreht
der einen Anschlag war in etwa 20 Meter
entfernt es war tatsächlich Glück dass
er hinter dem Fahrzeug stattfand und
nicht auf der anderen Seite ansonsten
hat man statt schnelle getroffen es gab
allerdings auch zwei Kollegen die
verletzt wurden es war insgesamt so als
wäre als wäre das auch als wäre das
gezielt gewesen ist nicht immer sind
seine Einsätze so extrem doch die Arbeit
der Feuerwehrleute direkt hinter der
Kampflinie verlangt nilstal sehr viel ab
wenn ich dann mit den Kollegen ausfahre
dann fahre ich in der Regel wie gesagt
zu Waldbränden Fahrzeuge zur
zerstörten Häusern
Industrieanlage werden und es ist häufig
häufig ist es wirklich rein Zivil ist
kein Militär da ist ein Drohnen die auch
auf kleine Häuser runtergehen das ist
furchtbar
und dabei ist für ihn und die anderen
Helfer in der Ukraine immer die Angst
wieder ins Kreuz Feuer zu geraten
ein längeres Interview mit Nils Tal
findet ihr in der ZDF Mediathek auch
Präsident selenski wirft Russland
gezielte Angriffe auf Einsatzkräfte vor
so geschehen am Montag in einem
Raketenangriff wurden mindestens 9
Menschen getötet etliche verletzt Anne
dort im prokowski gab es furchtbare
Zerstörung auch ein Hotel wurde
getroffen wo eigentlich Mitarbeiter von
NGOs und Journalisten auch häufig wohnen
was da genau passiert und warum wurde
auch so ein Gebäude zum Ziel
getroffen wurde vor allen Dingen ein
Wohngebäude mit Apartments das direkt
neben diesem Hotel sich befand das Hotel
war zum Zeitpunkt des Angriffs leer
offenbar geräumt da hatten sich vorher
oft Soldaten auf Fronturlaub aufgehalten
auch viele internationale Journalisten
dieses Hotel war offenbar leer aber wie
gesagt es gab diesen Angriff auf ein
Wohngebäude mit Toten mit Verletzten
Rettungskräfte Polizei sind dann dorthin
geeilt um zu helfen und als sie dann
sozusagen dort waren ihre Arbeit
begonnen hatten nach 40 Minuten haben
die Russen an der exakten Stelle
haben diese exakte Stelle noch einmal
angegriffen und dann gab es eben noch
mal zusätzlicher tote verletzte der
Leiter des ukrainischen Zivilschutzes
der hat das eine Menschenjagd genannt
die als einzig und allein darauf
abgezielt hätte Menschen die anderen
helfen wollten zu töten also die
Empörung darüber und auch das Entsetzen
ist sehr groß hier in der Ukraine zum
Schluss noch die Frage es gab in der
Vergangenheit auch Vorwürfe vor einem
Jahr zum Beispiel von mehreren
Menschenrechtsorganisationen dass die
ukrainischen Truppen gezielt sie wieder
Einrichtungen die Schulen oder
Krankenhäuser als Militär Posten
benutzen würden was weißt Du darüber ne
ja das war dieser berühmte Bericht von
Amnesty International aus dem
vergangenen August damals war ich auch
in der Ukraine habe mit vielen
gesprochen und bin auf großes Entsetzen
im purerung gestoßen Präsident selensky
hat damals gesagt man stelle hier Opfer
und Täter auf eine Ebene die Leiterin
der von Amnesty International in der
Ukraine die es aus Protest sogar
zurückgetreten und der Hintergrund ist
natürlich der die Ukraine ist
angegriffen worden von den Russen dieser
dieser russische Angriffskrieg der
dauert jetzt schon fast anderthalb Jahre
er wird mit unerbittlicher Härte geführt
und in Städten wie Herr Sonne wo wir
waren natürlich sind da auch ukrainische
Soldaten im Zentrum in den Wohngebieten
haben wir die nicht gesehen aber
natürlich haben wir auch ukraineische
Artillerie gehört die selbstverständlich
auch auf die andere Seite dieses Flusses
schießt weil natürlich das Ziel ist
diese besetzten ukrainischen Gebiete von
den Russen besetzte Gebiete zurück zu
gewinnen und das ist das oberste Ziel
der Ukraine und natürlich kommt dieses
Militär zum Einsatz Einschätzung von ZDF
reporterin Anne Brühl live für uns in
Odessa vielen Dank an alle
und jetzt habe ich gesehen ihr habt
viele Fragen an Markus Keup unseren
Militärexperten der mir jetzt nun wieder
zugeschaltet ist und deswegen möchte ich
auch sofort auf diese Fragen eingehen
und zwar starten wir doch einfach mal
wir hatten ja vorher hatten sie für uns
eingeschätzt wie die Ukraine ja versucht
im Moment auch die die
Ukraine ich bin hier parallel an diesem
sprechen das funktioniert schlecht also
wie die Ukraine versucht den Nachschub
an die russischen Truppen auch zu
unterbrechen es gibt eine Frage von Leon
hier bei YouTube der möchte wissen was
könnte die Ukraine mit einem Durchbruch
am nibro erreichen welche Möglichkeiten
würden sich dann ergeben auch zur Krim
also der User meint wahrscheinlich dass
das die Ukraine über den Fluss setzen
würde also sprich an ein Flussübergang
Wagen jetzt wo das das Reservoir von
nowakaovka ausgetrocknet ist ja dass das
ist eine These die sie die sie ab und zu
hören ich glaube ehrlich gesagt nicht
daran aus verschiedenen Gründen also
zunächst mal fließt immer noch der der
nipro bzw
durch ähm der ist an der Stelle noch
etwas so breit wie der Oberrhein also
sprich das das so ausgelaufen aber der
Fluss ist immer noch da das heißt also
das das wäre ein ein komplexer
amphibischer Übergang weil sie müssen ja
das gesamte schwere Material
organisieren und da hinüber schaffen und
zwar nicht nur über den Fluss sondern
jetzt auch über dieses System von
Sandbänken und und kleinen Land in sich
hin dass ich da gebildet hat nach dem
Ablauf des Resorts das Problem ist dass
die russische Artillerie das sehr sehr
gut beobachten und auch sehr gut unter
Beschuss nehmen
könnte also solche solche amphibischen
Übergänge überflüsse sind sind meistens
nicht nur logistisch gefährlich sondern
auch operativ also wir erinnern uns
vielleicht an den Zweiten Weltkrieg an
die an die Übergänge der Amerikaner bei
Arnheim und bei einem in der Operation
market Gaben wie extrem verlustrecht das
war mit mit großen Truppen verwenden und
schweren Material überflüsse zu setzen
selbst wenn sie jetzt nicht mehr so
breit sind wie früher ich glaube aus
diesem Gründen eher nicht daran in es
macht auch logistisch keinen Sinn weil
da würden sie ihre Kräfte eher
verzetteln das heißt also sie würden
jetzt noch mehr verschiedene Punkte
aufmachen wo sie wo sie versuchen
vorzustoßen man muss sich im Klaren sein
die die ukrainische gegen Offensive ist
ja immer noch in der Phase wo man quasi
die die Befestigung der Russen so ein
bisschen antestet ja also man schaut wo
sind die Schwachstellen wo komme ich am
ehesten durch mit robotine hat man jetzt
eine solche Schwachstelle gefunden
gleichzeitig und behält man andere opt
Person in in bachmut und so weiter also
man man erhält die Kampfhandlungen um
die Russen quasi zu zwingen ihre
Logistik immer hin und her zu schieben
einer meiner Follower auf Twitter hat es
mal Russen Ping Pong genannt ich fand
den Namen sehr sehr treffend weil sie
eben halt sehen die die Frontlinie und
auch das Grabensystem das ist halt sehr
sehr lang und je mehr Sie die russische
Logistik beeinträchtigen oder
abschneiden können desto schwieriger
fällt es in Russen eben dieses hin und
her zu machen das heißt also angenommen
es ist würde sowas kommen also ein ein
beabsichtigter Übergang über den EPO
dann würde ich das eher als
ablenkungsaktion werden oder eben als
versucht die russische Logistik so ein
bisschen wegzuziehen von der robotine
Ecke aber ich glaube nicht dass das
militärische Operation Erfolg hätte wir
bleiben bei ihrer Einschätzung und der
Analyse der aktuellen Frontlinie es gibt
eine Frage von einem User Userin mit dem
Namen skurril geht das meint damit die
Offensive in dem Tempo so weiter oder
sind die zweiten und dritten Linien
nicht so stark ist die Frage
es ist keine Frage von Tempo es ist eine
Frage der Massierung von Kräften das
heißt bei so einem Grabensystem kommt es
darauf an wie ich vorhin schon gesagt
habe sie müssen den Punkt finden wo der
Gegner am schwächsten steht bzw wo sie
ihm am besten die hinterlandlogistik
abschneiden können und dann kann sich
das klar machen wenn man jetzt noch mal
auf die Karte schaut ähm also die die
Ortschaft die ich immer wieder erwähne
nämlich robotine wenn sie mal gucken wo
führt eigentlich die Straße
t0408 hin also in in welche Richtung
wenn sie von von robertine aus einfach
südlich gehen also sehen ähm sie finden
auf der auf der Karte einfach mal den
Ort oder rechts und gehen von dort aus
südlich und dann kommen sie nämlich
genau in die Richtung wo die Ukraine
gerade die hinterlandlogistik
abschneidet nämlich in Richtung
also wo die wo die Autobahn M18 von
Süden quasi hinein also von von der
Creme aus und und genau das ist genau
das ist die Idee also sie stoßen von
oreche jetzt über robotine in Richtung
topmarkt vor das ist ein wichtiger
Straßen und Eisenbahnknotenpunkt und
gleichzeitig ist eben die
hinterlandlogistik die die Russen nach
talkmak hineinbringen müssen die
verläuft eben über mellitopol über die
Autobahn M18 und dann eben über die über
die Krim Brücken die jetzt beschossen
worden sind mit Storm sie sehen dahinter
die Idee ja und und darum geht's
eigentlich so ein Komplex aufzubauen
Schwachpunkt im Grabensystem mit
gleichzeitigen Ausschalten der
Hinterland Logistik und da müssen sie
die Kräfte drauf konzentrieren
und Fakt ist natürlich auch es gibt
viele Tote und Verwundete jetzt bei
dieser Offensive im Süden und Osten des
Landes und auch dazu gibt es Fragen ein
User Userin mit dem Namen kleines
Schreckgespenst fragt sich bei Youtube
die Ukraine soll bislang durch die
Offensive fast 46.000 Soldaten verloren
haben kurze Einschub von mir ich glaube
die Ukraine die hält das ziemlich zurück
natürlich wie viele Soldaten sie
wirklich verloren hat nichtsdestotrotz
also hat viele Soldaten verloren wie
lange denkt Herr Kolb dass dies aufrecht
zu erhalten ist ja
das ist auch ein Argument dass das immer
mal wieder kommt nach dem Motto wie
lange kann die Ukraine durchhalten wer
erinnern und Sie haben ja mal angefangen
mit drei Tagen bei gewissen Exponenten
in deutschen Talkshows mittlerweile sind
wir ich ich habe jetzt selber nicht so
genau mitgezählt am Tag 521
man möge mich korrigieren falls ich mich
jetzt gerade irre aber so schnell gehen
der Ukraine die Kräfte nicht aus und so
schnell ist der Krieg nicht vorbei das
muss man klar sagen natürlich sind
Verlustzahlen letztlich Propaganda und
Verlustzahlen beim Personal sind eben
besonders schwer zu messen ich empfehle
deswegen immer man soll sich nicht so
sehr auf die Mannschaft Stärken
beziehen weil es ist schwer davon lässt
sich jetzt Zahlen zu finden sondern auf
das Material also auf die logistiken da
gibt es ja zum Beispiel die ohrrixliste
wo man eben mit Bild und Video Beweis
arbeiten kann also wo man sehr viel sehr
viel bessere Zahlen hat ich würde
ansonsten sagen der der Krieg ist in
dieser Phase immer noch ein starken
mechanisierter Krieg das heißt also wir
sehen ja gerade
z.B was wir im Ersten Weltkrieg gesehen
haben also massierte Angriffswellen von
leicht bewaffneter in Verträge gerade
das sehen wir nicht sondern wir sehen im
Wesentlichen Geräte die und und
Maschinen die in der Gegend herumfahren
oder eben gerettet die stehen also
stationäre Artillerie und und schießen
insofern würde ich mich für die
Beurteilung dieser Kriegsführung nicht
so sehr Aufhängen an jetzt realistischen
oder oder einige Maßen Verlustzahlen
sondern wirklich den Krieg als
mechanisierte Operation zu betrachten
das heißt eben mehr von von den
Maschinen her und und von der Logistik
der Krieg ist noch nicht vorbei sagten
sie gerade sie sagten aber auch mal bei
uns in der Sendung da zählt gleich eine
user-frage drauf ab unter anderem auch
bei uns in der Sendung und dazu komme
ich jetzt zu dieser User Frage von einem
User Userin iche Frage an Herrn Kolb
bleibt es bei ihrer Meinung dass
Russland ungefähr im Oktober den Krieg
militärisch verlieren wird und welche
Hinweise deuten darauf hin bleiben Sie
dabei
also bevor man mich immer wieder falsch
zitiert möchte ich kurz darauf hinweisen
bitte lesen Sie das Interview dass ich
der NZZ im März diesen Jahres gegeben
habe ihn original text ja damit Sie mich
nicht falsch zitieren ich habe gesagt
dass meiner Einschätzung nach der Krieg
für Russland im Oktober strategisch
verloren sein wird und jetzt kommt auch
wenn die Kampfhandlungen dann noch
weitergehen das heißt es ist durchaus
möglich dass die Russen dass nicht
einsehen und dann einfach sagen okay wir
wir bleiben jetzt hier und wir kämpfen
weiter für ich habe damals in dem
Interview so ein bisschen die parallele
gezogen mit 1944 also die strategische
Lage ist so dass sie sagen okay das
weiterkämpfen hat keinen Sinn mehr wir
kriegen die Logistik nicht mehr
entsprechend zu sammeln und wir haben
auch nicht mehr materiell die
Möglichkeiten diesen Krieg für uns zu
entscheiden daraus würde sich die
logische Schlussfolgerung ergeben
Rückzug und Krieg einstellen es ist
möglich dass die Russen zu der
Erkenntnis kommt und dann entsprechend
handeln es ist möglich dass sie keine
Ahnung vielleicht das das Putin sich so
ein bisschen weigert die Realität dann
zur Kenntnis zu nehmen und sagt nein ihr
bleibt hier und ihr kämpft bis zum
letzten Mal aber das das ändert nichts
an den strategischen Verhältnissen und
ich sage es immer wieder strategische
Verhältnisse haben vor allem zu tun mit
der Abnutzung der russischen Truppen und
mit der zunehmenden Unmöglichkeit diese
Truppen logistisch zu versorgen und in
dem Kontext bitte ich meine Äußerung zu
verstehen und jetzt nach dieser langen
langen Vorrede kommt die Antwort ja ich
bin nach wie vor dieser Ansicht und ich
denke schon dass wir den Sommer und den
Herbst über durchaus noch Bewegung sehen
werden an der Frauen das ist halt immer
so im Mediengeschäft wenn man die
Logistik spricht zumindest nach nach
meiner Auffassung eine andere Sprache
eine große Herausforderung für die
ukrainischen Truppen das haben wir in
den letzten Sendung und Wochen auch
immer wieder gelernt und hier diskutiert
ist der Fakt das Russland einfach
etliche Quadratkilometer vermietert wir
schauen mal auch ganz kurz hier auf
Bilder wie das dort aussieht es sind
also Kilometer tief gestaffelte Anlagen
die die russisch besetzten Gebiete
absichern sollen zuerst kommen
Minenfelder die einen Angriff erschweren
sogenannte Drachenzähne aus Beton
verhindern das Panzer schnell
durchkommen aus gehobene Schützengräben
die bieten Schutz oder säulenschutz
bieten für die russischen Soldaten und
dann kommen Panzergräben und bilden die
Verteidigungslinie mit Artillerie mit
Raketenwerfern und dazu gibt es auch
Fragen bei uns im Stream User Leon fragt
sich was kann denn die Ukraine gegen
diese ganzen Minenfelder machen hat sie
genügend minenräumfahrzeuge
ich muss zu der Grafik nächstes mal
sagen die Grafik muss man eher
didaktisch verstehen die die hat jetzt
quasi alle möglichen Elemente die die so
eine Befestigungslinie haben kann in
eine Grafik gepackt also die die Frauen
sieht nicht überall so aus ja es gibt
manche Orts auch überhaupt keine
Befestigung sondern natürliche
Hindernisse hinter die man Artillerie
gestellt hat also man nimmt dann quasi
den Naturraum als als natürliche
Abwehrlinie aber jetzt auf die Frage was
was kann man tun also das große Problem
da bin ich wieder bei einem meiner
Lieblingsthemen nämlich Besonnenheit ja
ist dass man den Russen die Zeit gegeben
hat diese Befestigungslinien überhaupt
mal aufzubauen ja hätte man den hätte
man den den Ukrainern Panzer geliefert
also sechs bis acht Monate vorher also
zu dem Zeitpunkt wo es wirklich passiert
ist also sagen wir gegen im Herbst oder
gegen Ende 22 dann hätten wir eine
völlig andere Lage in der Ukraine dann
hätten die großen nämlich gar keine Zeit
gehabt dieses umfassende System zu bauen
also da dass man am Rande bemerkt aber
ähm wie wie kommen Sie durch so ein
System da sind wir bei meinem zweiten
Lieblingsthema F16 ähm im Moment wird
die Ukraine gezwungen in einer Weise zu
kämpfen wie keine NATO Armee es tun
würde normalerweise deswegen haben sie
zum Beispiel in Irak 2003 gesehen das
erste was sie machen würden und solche
Befestigungsanlagen rauszunehmen ist
totale Luft Überlegenheit herstellen aus
der Luft alles kaputt machen die diese
ganzen Minen die dort verlegt sind eben
mit luftmitteln ausschalten und dann am
Boden vorstoßen weil die Ukraine keine
luftmittel hat auch hier wieder das
Thema Besonnenheit bzw sie erst
wahrscheinlich in diesem Herbst Winter
erhalten wird ist sie also gezwungen
sich quasi langsam am Boden voran zu
graben und gleichzeitig eben zu
versuchen die russische Artillerie aus
der Entfernung auszuschalten
das ist also eine Art und Weise die die
schwierig ist zu zur kämpfen und die
natürlich auch viel viel langsamer geht
ja also normalerweise wäre so eine
Operation in wenigen Wochen beendet wenn
sie Luft Überlegenheit hätten also was
müssen Sie stattdessen machen
minenräumfahrzeuge ist ein Stichwort ja
ähm also Minen Räumen zunächst man das
ist eigentlich das Hauptproblem also
nicht so sehr die russischen
Mannschaften in den Gräben setzen
sondern der massive minengürtel der
entlang dieser ganzen Front liegt also
die die Schätzung die mir vorliegen
sagen etwa 8 Millionen sind
entlang der gesamten Frontlinie verlegt
worden und die müssen sie erst mal
rausbekommen
jetzt normalerweise würden sie sowas mit
line charges machen das heißt also sie
schießen eine Spezialmunition in das
Minenfeld und die bringt die Minen in
einem bestimmten engen Korridor zum
Explodieren das Problem ist sie bekommen
damit aber nicht das ganze minenfeldweg
sondern nur so ein Schlauch und das
führt dazu dass sie die Fahrzeuge eng
hintereinander gestaffelt durch einen
engen Schlauch den durchschicken und
damit generieren Sie natürlich Ziele für
die russische Artillerie also das das
hat die Ukraine zu Beginn dagegen
Offensive versucht das ging nicht gut
ähm da hatten wir dann diese Bilder von
den von den abgeschlossenen Bradleys die
dahinter stehen das heißt also da
anschaut ist in keiner keine Option es
sei denn Sie setzen 7 massiert ein ähm
das können sie noch machen sie können
Panzer hören nehmen also Pioniere die in
die Minenfelder vorkriechen und das von
Hand erledigen das geht aber viel zu
langsam ich würde sagen dass das was am
ehesten gegen die Mannschaften in den
Gräben das ist natürlich clustermunition
aber das hilft ihnen nicht gegen die
Minenfelder sie sehen also es gibt keine
keine schnellen Lösungen ja sondern
durch diese Minenfelder erstmal
durchzukommen das ist eigentlich die
Hauptaufgabe ich denke das ist auch der
Grund warum es langsamer geht als viele
erwartet haben es wird nicht mehr so
sehr ein Thema sein in diesem Herbst
Winter also sobald die Ukraine die
ersten Kampfflugzeuge bekommt und dann
tatsächlich auch zu aus der Luft
entsprechend Operationen starten kann
aber für den Moment muss man einfach
sich ein bisschen zügeln und und darf
nicht so viel erwarten was die was die
Geschwindigkeit bei mir angeht
dann gehen wir doch mal jetzt auf die
jüngsten Forderungen der Ukraine ein
nach Marschflugkörpern vom Typ Taurus
wir haben dazu auch eine Grafik die wir
hier auf einem hochkant Bildschirm
zeigen können hoffentlich könnt ihr das
alle gut sehen also die Ukraine fordert
diese marschflugkörpertyp Taurus um eben
Ausstellung der russischen Streitkräfte
weit hinter der Frontlinie angreifen zu
können würden die dann wirklich den
Durchbruch für die Ukraine bringen das
ist da ihre Einschätzung
ja also sie würden auf jeden Fall an
entscheidenden Vorteil bringen also man
kann sich das ganz einfach vorstellen
wir haben ja jetzt in den letzten Wochen
viel gelernt über Storm Shadow und Skype
das ist im Prinzip die gleiche
Technologie es gibt so minimale
Unterschiede aber Storm Shadow und Skype
sind eigentlich eine britisch
französische
Gemeinschaftsentwicklung und das
Konkurrenzmodell dazu ist im Prinzip
Taurus das ist also eine Deutsch
schwedische Gemeinschaftsentwicklung
funktioniert aber eigentlich nach dem
gleichen Prinzip also es ist ein
Marschflugkörper der eine relativ große
Reichweite hat nämlich bis zu 250 km der
eine doppelte Penetration hat das heißt
also das sind zwei Gefechtsköpfe der
erste schlägt normalerweise ein und
beseitigt irgendeinen ein starkes
Hindernis also zum Beispiel die Fahrbahn
von einer Brücke und ähm aktiviert ein
zweiten Geschoss Pfeil also der der dann
weiter fliegt nachdem die erste
Charge explodiert ist und der
trifft dann präzise aber auch
Wasserkraft also zum Beispiel den
Brückenpfeiler das haben wir bei Sound
Shadow eigentlich gesehen
ja also dieser dieser dieser Durchschlag
erst durch die Fahrbahn und danach wird
der Brückenpfeiler getroffen und Taurus
funktioniert im Prinzip genauso also
auch mit mit ähnlicher Reichweite mit
mit ähnlichem Wahrheit mit ähnlicher
Durchschlagskraft und natürlich würde
das der Ukraine helfen die russische
Logistik nachhaltig zu beschädigen eben
indem sie weiterhin die Brücken
beschießt also zum Beispiel auch die
Brücke dann von Allianz herausnimmt oder
andere Ziele eben weit im Hinterland
trifft und wir erinnern uns die warum
eigentlich die die russischen
Verteidigungslinien so gebaut worden
sind wie sie gebaut wurden oder warum
die Russen sich so aufgestellt haben wie
sie es getan haben sie haben nämlich
gedacht okay die Ukraine haben Heimat
bekommen von den Amerikanern können wir
auch alle mittlerweile Heimat hat aber
zwei Probleme erstens es ist Boden
gebunden das heißt also sie können zwar
verschieben aber es dauert eine gewisse
Zeit und zweitens hat eine maximale
Reichweite von 70 80 Kilometer
bzw Taurus sind aus der Luft abgefeuerte
Systeme und sie haben eine Reichweite
von bis zu 250 Kilometern das heißt also
dieses russische Kalkül wir ziehen uns
nur einfach hinter diesen Radius von 80
km zurück und dann haben wir unsere Ruhe
das funktioniert nicht mehr und das
bekommt im Moment gerade das russische
Hauptquartieren gerne chest äh zu spüren
von dort aus wird nämlich die russische
südporn kontrolliert und der das
Hauptquartier ist von den Ukrainern
bereits beschlossen worden mit Storm und
das sehen sie eben dieses viel Kalorien
ja also sie sehen Sie sie erreichen mit
dieser Waffe das gesamte russische
Hinterland die gesamten
Straßenverbindung bis bald auf die Krimi
hinein bis an die gesamte also auf mehr
und schwarz mehr Küsten das ist
eigentlich der der strategische Vorteil
und wenn sie jetzt überlegen die
Bundeswehr hat also auf dem Papier 600
Stück Taurus
davon dürfte na ja so die Hälfte
vielleicht einsatzfähig sein von von dem
was man jetzt gelesen hat in den letzten
Wochen und natürlich würde dass der
Ukrainer einen großen militärischen
Vorteil bieten ja zum Schluss möchte ich
Ihnen gerne noch eine Frage aus dem
Stream von einem User mit dem Namen
Richard Stellen geht in Richtung
Ausblick er fragt sich was kann sich
nach weiteren fünf bis zehn Monaten
Krieg für die Ukraine an der Lage
realistisch verbessern
von jetzt an würde der Krieg fünf bis
zehn Monate weiter du verstehst das ja
ja also unter dieser Annahme da würde
ich zwei Entwicklungen sehen also zum
ersten ähm eine deutlich gesteigerte
luftkampffähigkeit der Ukraine also
sprich sobald sie F 16 bekommt ich sage
immer wieder ist es nicht eine Frage von
ob es ist nur eine Frage wann und von
welchen Nation ich vermute mal
Niederlande und Dänemark werden da eine
Koalition der Willigen anführen das
zweite ist natürlich die weiter
voranschreitende Abnutzung der
klassischen schweren Geräte und da
müssen wir insbesondere auf die
Artillerie gucken also wenn wir jetzt
mal die die juli Verlustquote angucken
im Juli hat Russland 90 Artillerie
Systeme also schwere Artillerie verloren
das ist 50% mehr als in Durchschnitt der
vergangenen Monate das heißt also die
Ukraine schaltet im Moment gezielt
russische Artillerie aus und wenn das so
weitergeht dann würde ich Voraussagen
dann müsste die russische Artillerie
Frequenz sinken womit sich also auch die
Angriffe auf die zivilen Infrastrukturen
Klammer auf natürlich alles
Kriegsverbrechen Den Haag zählt mit ne
Klammer zu auf die Zivilbevölkerung auf
die Rettungskräfte die wir gesehen haben
noch mal alles Kriegsverbrechen Den Haag
zählt mit Klammer zu das müsste sich
deutlich vermindern und wenn Sie wenn
Sie das jetzt zusammen nehmen also die
die Abnutzung der Artillerie die das
zunehmende abschneidende Logistik und
und der der Druck gegen die russischen
Graben Linien dann denke ich schon dass
wir auf sich von 5 bis 10 Monaten an
strategische Entscheidung in diesem
Krieg haben sollten wie gesagt ich habe
es schon etwas früher prognostiziert
aber auch ich kann mich irren wie jeder
Mensch aber ich habe keinen Zweifel am
strategischen Ausgang dieses Krieges
Einschätzung von Militärexperte Markus
Keup auch heute wieder vielen Dank dass
Sie sich so viel Zeit für uns genommen
für die Fragen genommen haben danke
schön ja schönen Abend noch ebenso und
schönen Abend auch für euch ich hoffe
das war interessant für euch diskutiert
gerne noch weiter wenn ihr mögt im
Stream und seid gerne auch beim nächsten
Mal wieder dabei markus war mit
Sicherheit nicht zum letzten Mal bei uns
zu Gast bis dahin schönen Abend tschüss